it's just such an incredible landscape
it just has an effect on everybody who
comes here it was Theodore Roosevelt who
called the Grand Canyon the one great
site which every American should see he
probably didn't mean all at the same
time I think one of the most pressing
issues in the park today is the number
of people that we get on an annual basis
on even the coldest morning they gather
on the south rim of the canyon to catch
the first warmth of a spring day there
are a lot of people and everyone wants
to take pictures and you just have to
take it very easy and and try not to
step on anyone take turns and take time
politeness comes right back in 1974
visitation was at 2.2 million and back
then the National Park Service was
concerned about the level of visitation
and the experience that our visitors
were kidding now troopers if you haven't
figured this out already this is not a
pony ride at Disneyland every day dozens
of people pay to experience the Grand
Canyon from the back of them you will
try to show you a trip you never forget
you'll join a unique group of people
they get to see this Canyon let me know
if you do that group is not as exclusive
as it used to be reservations for
overnight rides into the canyon are
recommended more than a year in advance
it is breathtaking I mean you have to
see this you really really have to come
and see it can't explain to anybody like
in a picture or anything you have to
come and see it because it is
breathtaking getting away from the rim
provides an experience impossible to get
at a roadside overlooked but each
footstep adds to the wear and tear on
the trails and on a canyon that is more
fragile than a
fears the soils are very shallow we find
that a one footstep off trail and as an
invitation for others to follow and we
get basically we get user-defined trails
the Grand Canyon continues to astound no
matter the challenges it faces it's been
called an open book into the history of
the earth a story of countless millennia
with an ending that is still being
written